blue face masks are common sight in city
centres around britain
currently only essential shops are open
but as lockdowns are loosened people
will still be wearing masks for months
or even years to come
and that means an ongoing nightmare for
the environment
both legs are swollen they will need
some anti-inflammatories
this video shows staff at a wildlife
hospital helping a bird that's been
caught up in discarded litter
it's a face mask one of the disposable
surgical face coverings made of plastic
campaign group keep britain tidy have
found disposable masks and gloves
at 14 of sites they've surveyed since
last summer
they say such discarded items are now
even more common than plastic
bags were before a compulsory charge for
the bags came in
more than a hundred million disposable
face masks like this get thrown away
across the uk
every single week that's enough to cover
more than 230 soccer pitches
now a recent survey found 70 percent of
people using disposable masks
didn't realize they were using
single-use plastics and nearly one in
five thought they could be recycled
which isn't the case i know it's going
to be waste but these are the quickest
and the most easiest ones to use
put on take out go again do you know
what i mean
with these types that i've got they're
not washable they're not reusable
so you have to be mindful where you put
them i have noticed a lot more of them
lying about as people discard them
but i haven't given any real thought as
to what happens to them afterwards
the problem with single-use plastic
masks is they'll end up in a landfill
site like this
in an incinerator or simply discarded
researchers at university college london
say if every person in the uk used one
disposable mask
every day for a year it would create 124
000
tons of waste half of which would be
unrecyclable contaminated plastic
when we use it in healthcare they're
classed as clinical wastes
so then healthcare workers will put it
in
stay the yellow bins so then like they
are
separated from general their general
waste and then taken
to incineration for the public domain
there
isn't actually this system yet at this
factory they're trying to provide an
alternative
their masks are based on specifications
from aldehyde children's hospital in
liverpool
which gets a percentage of the sales
they have an antiviral coating
and like other such masks can be washed
and reused
had to be something that was always
practical comfortable
easy to wear and can be produced locally
so the the mask and the design that
we've come up with is
ethical sustainable and entirely made in
the uk
it looks like face masks will be part of
many people's lives at least in the
short term
whatever kind they wear they're being
urged to consider where it comes from
and where it'll end up nadine barber al
jazeera
london